how's it going bros today we are
literally just gonna watch funny videos
go haha no gimmick no donations
just good time if that sounds good let's
dive into it
anytime I see one of these birds I'm
like I want a bird but I know I'll get
the worst bird it'll just [__]
everywhere so stop tricking me Birds I'm
not getting one of you stupid bird that
sent me this
sir
[Laughter]
why it wasn't me I swear could have been
anyone excuse me sir how much dog food
is that Jesus Christ it's funny because
with Momo our tiny one it's the complete
opposite she loves to I don't know
random stuff and as soon as we go what
what you got there
she'll bolt no matter what even if she
doesn't want it she'll take it eat it
swallow it so I commend that dog
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the perfect crime they say it doesn't
exist before we continue quick word from
sponsor this video is brought to you by
G fuel if you've never tried G fuel
you're missing out what are you doing
Now's the Time to test it out because we
have the highest sale that it has ever
been on GPU for the next 48 hours only
37 up it's practically a steal everyone
that is extremely handsome smart and
intelligent already drinks G fuel
they are going to take advantage of this
offer but I'm looking at you who's never
even tried YouTube 30 enough to ftla
apparently
this is related to all the starter kits
part of the phone would you feel is that
they have so many flavors and everyone
has their own personal favorites
PewDiePie flavor but you can try out the
starter kits enter your code puts37 to
get access to this you're welcome that's
the biggest sale they've ever done so
seven flavors for 15 bucks you just
can't beat that the best flavor is
PewDiePie flavor but I also love the
Dragon Ball Z kamehara and Naruto Sage
Mode as you guys know
I love G fuel gives me the energy to
record my videos keep me riding in a
smooth balance I absolutely love it you
won't regret it if you haven't tested
out I actually I actually love GPU in
case this isn't obvious I drink it every
day
it's delicious so what are you waiting
for take advantage of this deal 30 off
huge 37 you're welcome pack the
dishwasher and then I'm back
the doodle is like this hey hey relax
it's gonna be all right see this basket
thing
I don't know how it happens if it's the
house or what
but any dirty clothes you put in this
basket
somehow the next day they're just clean
folded and in a perfect pile on your bed
you're not serious I couldn't believe
the first either but it just keeps
happening
there's other things too plates Cutlery
pizza boxes dirty tissues anything you
leave on this coffee table
just vanishes overnight I mean sometimes
I'll see how far I can push this thing
and hold your sleeves everywhere this is
Marta with the dishwasher no this is it
with the trash no with the Amazon boxes
It's Magic it just disappeared it's
magic no she wouldn't have left me this
would have think happened I heard her
get up in the middle of the night to get
a drink or something she must have
fallen onto the magic coffee table and
just vanished
insane no he's not insane I've got the
same coffee
got the same coffee table she cleans the
coffee table that's magic actually my
husband gearing up to ask me if we have
any plans this weekend even though I had
told him five times already a 100
I'm terrified every time
first four goes straight into the trash
at least usually I'm the fifth time it
registers oh yes we have plans that's
right
[Music]
yeah remember that there's no mud
there's no mind
there's no mountains
makes a better actually
him trying to explain he doesn't want to
cut it because it's hot yes it's too
high I'm high every night I'm hot I have
to remove everything I'll take those ice
blocks of feet and I thank them happily
but if it's too hot it's too hot man
excuse me I've got to be going why
something
it has come to my attention it's not
that bad is it people really it's
uncomfortable when you're like a
teenager come on
come on
he's protector of the Seven Realms
for Elixir upset I think he needs some
space
I love that beautiful
[Music]
there's no way she thought I was
thrilled okay now I want a bird just not
a live one so I can do this he opened me
window I think birds can do that and I
think you should know that hey more bird
related memes
tired of being a bird
[Music]
I got it seen that last video I get it
it
[Music]
I'm very confused but I think the dog
won well played dog we don't do that put
it down please
look she's happy
no I see
God
these are so good I can't remember even
if I show this but it's so funny I don't
know what it is kids don't unders like
their brains get stuck and they can't
keep doing what they're doing and it's
hilarious two hands it will not happen
to my child no don't give up two hands
he's giving up
look at him
come on
what are you doing there you go here we
go
that's okay don't worry about those you
got it feed that dogging don't miss all
right
why do people want these six Jesus no
empathy for a child apparently I was
joking maybe they are too
when you wake up before her and see her
still sleeping
[Music]
I mean yeah the dog is cute
what the dog dreaming of though
is the dog okay I don't understand is
this your elbow or is this your elbow
I gotta try it I got it right is this
your elbow
or is this your elbow
he doesn't care
look it's so funny because she's half
Pug half Chihuahua her right ear is down
like a pug but her left one is always up
like a shoe
you look like a meerkat
or a kangaroo
what is he doing
sounds like me deadlifting
oh God wait I personally don't find this
very funny if you go on this equipment
shouldn't have been used to move this
kind of product no
oh
apparently it's not funny box weighed's
40 pounds right away
Kevin it really like it's a big box but
come down bro just toss the damn Box
come down
for the registers
40 pounds
[Music]
oh
I'm dying
not funny moment to you again
now that we have a half Chihuahua I look
at all these swamis I'm like that's
hilarious and I don't think they're that
funny but anyway
[Music]
the other dog doesn't look too pleased
about it I gotta be honest child I
blesses the
with extra Scooby snay
hey that was smooth I guess he's done
with Edgar he's getting way too chunky
God it's all it's all wife or cats or
dumb kids
that's what gets me these days I don't
know
give it back
[Applause]
oh god oh yes oh God this is so funny
how is this real they always stayed Fair
has been calling competition
[Applause]
okay
divorce if anyone yells at me like that
[Music]
oh God
can you hear me you get yourself in here
right
here right one
you know you
know I want to get there on time right
right right
when I first last lady has centuries of
practice Mrs Henderson really I used to
get major secondhand embarrassment as a
kid watching this there was also Mom
calling contest for kids which I was
forced into entering and I'm realizing I
had suppressed that memory a long time
ago oh God
Iowa is there nothing else to do in Iowa
but this you gotta come up with
something else oh God trying the
microphone all right yeah I've seen this
comes out right it's so cute oh I should
say a period right oh oh I'm sorry wait
a minute
stop it grandma
breathe deep
okay what does that say
wait a minute I'll I'll read it okay
what is it say wait a minute I
read it okay stop reading what you're
saying is she answering me is she
talking back to me is that me
I mean I should be empathetic it's going
to be us when AI 5000 gbt does something
incomprehensible
there's a couple of happy couples there
aren't they enjoying a summer night at
Fenway Park
whoops
nickmarks
here you go bracky I know how much you
like wieners
how gay is my dog here's a sausage
Bailey would you like it
no
it's my dog game
all right one more here you go I know
you how much you like wieners
[Applause]
Mama it's here in my hand
come on
he's a little Psychopathic I'm not gonna
lie I don't know what I was expecting
really got a couple more
I love the caption the caption actually
made it funnier the cat said it's not a
[__] trails
for the shirt what kind of names were
these kids calling you uh at the pool
Meathead Fatso why but Wally the whale
Porky hog fat ass double wide Butterball
those sorts of things right yeah dumbass
chubby chub it's really horrible when
everyone call you stinky Blinky chubby
chungus and did you cry when they called
you
laughs
[Music]
I thought it would be crazy but that's
actually funny
to contact me absolutely John vacuum is
attached best Felix that's how you do it
come on
foreign
what's his problem oh my God
[Music]
what the hell is that
it's actual bully well that was fun
wasn't it did you just got that
you won congratulations hope you guys
are doing well and I'll see you guys in
the next video bye bye